content
[Music]
excellent so second time is the charm
great session
right
okay let's start catching
sorry about the technical difficulties
um uh thank you for coming to my talk uh
i'm dana and uh
uh today i'm going to talk to you about
the planet matching problem this is
joint work for detenting and my advisors
people who are jamming
so
um to start
let's consider a very simple math
problem
so
suppose you have a bipartite graph it is
a complete graph where
um
so you have n vertices to the left and
vertices to the right and the graph
contains all transferred edges and
suppose there are edge weights or costs
associated with each edge and these edge
weights are distributed by the
exponential so the question is
what is the cost of the minimum weight
matching
so in reality you can think of one side
of the vertices representing workers the
others are representing tasks and there
are costs associated with assigning
award curricular tasks and therefore um
we want to study okay what is the volume
of cost
and despite this problem being so simple
to state it actually turned out to be
quite a challenging mathematical problem
and it has been attacked by a line of
researchers and um
it only gave up resistance by in 2001
where elders proved rigorously that
the expected weight of the minimum
weight matching actually as n goes to
infinity converges to
a fixed limit of pi squared over six so
it's just really beautiful result
and it was also shown later rigorously
that um
for finite n this expected weight of the
minimum weight matching is exactly the
partial sum of the 1 over i squared
series
now let's jump to the more recent
timeline where a planted version of this
problem was considered
so under this planted version you assume
that there is actually a shoe perfect
matching that is planted in the graph
and it's considered the brown shoes
and
the model assumes that
there are these uh two edges and um all
those various fake edges and the edge
weights for the two and the fake hedges
they're exponential but with different
rates
now when there is an underlying tooth
planted but unknown then you have
some
natural statistical inference problems
that arise which is how well can you
recover the planet under matching
and
a natural solution is to consider okay
what is the
minimum
weight matching estimator and hatch how
does it perform statistically under this
planted model and this problem was
studied earlier by uh mohrami mohr and
sheep where they showed that
the shark statistical limit
happens uh at lambda equals four exactly
so that means when lamina is smaller
than four you have uh
um the minimum weight matching has to
suffer a constant fraction of
edge errors
and when lamb is larger than 4 the error
goes to 0.
so now with the
minimum weight matching cleanly analyzed
natural next step is to ask okay can we
do better statistically than the minimum
weight matching
and
the answer is actually you cannot do
better so the
minimum wage matching is the
statistically optimal and this is
answered in our paper this year
and we showed that lambda equals four is
indeed the sharp statistical threshold
for recovery
and um
in fact we are in our analysis we're no
longer restricted to considering only
exponential edge weights instead we can
allow the two edge weights and the fake
edge weights to follow arbitrary
distributions p and q
and
we not only consider
the complete graphs um but we actually
consider also
sparse graphs as well by assuming that
the edges on the fake edges they only
appear with probability d over n where d
can be as small as a constant which
corresponds to the sparse graphs and it
can be as large as all the way up to n
which corresponds to complete graphs
and we show that the statistical limit
for the recovery problem here depends
only on the average degree d
and the body chart coefficient
also known as the hellinger affinity
between p and q
and in the special case where the edge
weights are exponential and you have a
complete graph this statistical limit
collapses to lambda equals
which is attained by the minimum weight
matching
moreover we also show that near this
statistical image so when lambda is
equal to 4 minus some small epsilon
we're able to characterize the average
weight of the minimum
uh
sorry the average proportion of
mismatched edges
to be
scaling as e to the minus some small
constant
divided by square epsilon which shows
that the phase transition here is
infinitely smooth
now
so this result um
in a way it more or less gives a
complete answer to the sheriff's ratio
for the recovery problem under the
planted matching model
which makes me happy
however
uh more importantly i really think uh
what interests me most is uh the proof
strategies that are
um associated with this type of problems
and in fact we're analyzing or trying to
obtain with that obtain this result
first
um we tried some more conventional
methods including the second movement
method and also rate discharge arguments
and all these methods in the end they um
ended up failing
for us
and here is sort of a cartoon explaining
um the challenge in the analysis
basically to obtain a short statistical
image you are forced to look at the
posterior distribution
in particular you must look at
what is the um
posterior mass of
those matchings that are a fair distance
away from the shoes and because those
matchings um they potentially share a
large number of edges and the
interactions one stream ended up being
just overwhelming for us
and that means we had to develop some
new proof strategies in order to obtain
a
sharp analysis on the posterior
distribution
now um i'd like to take a step back from
here um
so um as a lot of you know there are
actually a lot of other planted problems
that are like this
um and the common theme of these
problems is really
there's
um so the shoe hidden signal
um does not it's not really represented
by some low-rank structure
and that means you cannot rely on some
more traditional methods like
spectral analysis or sdp relaxation and
this really brings in uh some new
challenges in both statistical analysis
and algorithmic design and really
i feel like that's a good thing because
it leaves a lot of room for researchers
to come up with our own
um new proof strategies
and uh another thing i like about this
type of problem is it's usually proved
by pictures combined with the
combinatorial arguments so overall it's
just a really fun playground to be in
finally i would like to just
make a short comment about the
computational gaps so for this
particular problem uh there is actually
no computational gap
because we know that the sharp threshold
is obtained by the minimum weight
matching or it can be
found via the hungarian algorithm in
polynomial time
however this is not true for
a lot of the other planet problems
listed and
for a lot of those problems there are
conjecture computational gaps
and it is still largely unknown how to
show those contracts your computational
gaps
and that's what i'm here to learn
thank you
i'm not sure i haven't looked at that
problem closely yeah but i i think some
of our
analysis techniques they may be applied
to the detection problem but at the
moment i can't tell you what's uh
sorry guys
unavoidably
um
you